et quatre prochains mois seront les plus
importants de votre fille
comme on en tire profit
[Applaudissements]
en ne s'arrêtant jamais d'attaqué
occasion ratée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les jeunes de l'académie attend des
années d'avoir un poste que tu as obtenu
en un clin d'oeil
on avait une entente ait le dernier mot
sur les joueurs et les entraîneurs
c'est la première entraîneuse de la mls
je l'avais pas ici
on disait que mon père était le roi des
grinta qui sera jamais comme ton père
soit il décide à jouer collectif soit je
te sors je suis dessous qui ne s'arrête
pas avant que la chasse soit fini
comment truquer un match si je peux être
très dangereux
[Musique]
j'ai pris de gros risques pour toi
comment tu va nous rembourser la dette
[Musique]
s'ils ont remporté cette victoire le
monde vous appartiendra
[Applaudissements]